ماسك ينفذ تهديده العلامه الزرقاء بثمانيه
دولارات شهريا ماساه طفله يمنيه ب 10
سنوات زوروا عمرها لتزويجها فوضى عامه
نشطاء مناخ يقتحمون مطارا ويوقفون
الطائرات هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في خطوه وصفت بالابرز ضمن تعديلات يجريها
الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك على منصه
تويتر التي اشتراها مؤخرا رسميا اصدرت
شركه تحديثا جديدا لنظام ايوس على اجهزه
ابل يسمحون الاشخاص والمؤسسات بالحصول على
علامات التوفيق الزرقاء مقابل دفع ثمانيه
دولارات شهريا بعد ان كانت مجانيا للافراد
والمنظمات المؤثره او البارزه التحديث
الجديد في عدد من الدول منها امريكا وكندا
وبريطانيا ونيوزيلندا للتاكد من عمله بشكل
سليم قبل اطلاقه حول العالم ويمثل هذا
التغيير نهايه نظام التحقق المعتاد في
تويتر الذي بدا عام 2009 لمنع انتحاله
هويات المشاهير والسياسيين
وائل اليمن حيث انتشاره حالتي تزويج
الفتيات القاصرات واخرها واقعه تزويج طفله
تبلغ من العمر عشره اعوام بعد تزوير
اوراقها الرسميه لتبدو في السن القانونيه
للزواج وبعد اكتشاف الجريمه بمدينه دمت
القي القبض على والد الفتاه والزوج
والامين الشرعي وتم ايداعهم سجن واعاده
الطفله الى امها بعد اشهر من اختين
الهولنديه امستردام حيث عرقل تحليقه بعض
الطائرات على مدرجات المطارات مستخدمين او
المطار مستخدمين الدراجاتهم الهوائيه
وخلال احتجاجهم جلسوا تحت عجلات الطائرات
الخاصه بين مظل اخرون يدورون حول الطائرات
رافعين لافتات تمدد بتاثير رحلات الجويه
واعتقلت السلطات العشرات منهم لاحقا
وفي مصر اصدلا بل اسدل القضاء الستاره على
القضيه التي شغلت المصريين لاشهر بمعاقبه
زوج عروس الاسماعيليه بالحبس لمده سنه مع
الشغل والنفاذ مع دفعه غرامه قدرها الف
جنيه المصري لتعديه عليها وبراته من تهمه
احتجازها دون ارادتها وكانت صاحبه الواقعه
المعروفه اعلاميه بعروس الاسماعيليه قد
حررت محضر ضد زوجها لاتهامه بتكرار
احتجازها وبضربها بعد الواقعه الشهيره
بالاعتداء عليها يوم زفافهما قبل ثمانيه
اشهر
في واقعه فريده من نوعها قررت احدى شركات
الطيران التركيه ادخال تعديلات على
الطائره لتمكين روميساء جلجي وهي اطول
امراه في العالم من السفر الى سان
فرانسيسكو بالولايات المتحده للمره الاولى
حيث ازالت سته مقاعد من الطائره
واستبددتها بسرير خاص لها الشابه التركيه
يبلغ طولها مترين وخمسه عشر سنتيمترا وهي
اطول امراه على قيد الحياه في العالم وفقه
موسوعه جينيس تعاني جلسه من متلازمه ويفر
وهي حاله وراثيه نادره تسبب فرطا في نمو
العظام
[موسيقى]